[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 para seguir el desarrollo
de la copa américa en eurocopas estos
son nuestros titulares colombia está en
las semifinales de la copa américa tras
un disputado 0 a 0 venció en los penales
a uruguay david ospina fue la figura en
la definición con dos atajadas
analizamos lo que dejó este encuentro
argentina derrotó 3 a 0 a ecuador y se
enfrentará a colombia en las semifinales
la albiceleste volvió a mostrar
altibajos pero sacó diferencias en el
final del partido le alcanza para soñar
con el título
inglaterra se ilusionante ucrania y está
en las semifinales de la eurocopa los
tres leones se impusieron 4 a 0 y
encarará en la recta final en wembley en
semifinales se enfrentarán a dinamarca
que despidió a la república checa
como en cada jornada nos acompaña sala
castro directora del diario vas colombia
bienvenidas a la ola federico un gusto
muy buen fútbol estamos viendo en ambos
torneos y empezamos por la copa américa
que ya conoce a sus cuatro
semifinalistas y uno de ellos es
colombia que superó en los penales a
uruguay fue un encuentro muy disputado
en el tiempo regular que terminó sin
goles en la definición solución david
ospina atajando los remates de josé
maría jiménez y matías viña duván zapata
davidson sánchez el jerry min y miguel
borja anotaron los cuatro disparos del
equipo de reinaldo rueda
edinson cavani y luis suárez no fallaron
para hacer esto los fanáticos en ambas
selecciones fueron las dos caras de una
misma moneda escuchamos que dijeron dos
de ellas tras el partido con uruguay que
es un equipo muy grande un equipo
mundial
ya estamos para cosas grandes siempre lo
hemos estado
uruguay yo todo de ti
el maestro solo cambio
d
ahora me quedo con lo que dijo esta
hincha colombiana más allá de la euforia
del triunfo lo que representa para
colombia vencer a una selección como
uruguay fue aparte de los futbolísticos
una muestra de carácter para el equipo
de rueda sin duda yo creo que el equipo
mostró competitividad ante un equipo
inagotable como es uruguay y eso es
fundamental en este momento del torneo y
luego también hay buenos niveles
individuales y creo que reinaldo rueda
está muy satisfecho en eso por un lado
lo que logran barrios y cuéllar en esa
primera línea de contención es tiempo es
importante es interesante da solidez al
juego de colombia
luís díaz aparece como un jugador
absolutamente desequilibrante y la
figura de rafael santos borre como uno
de los jugadores más completos de
colombia un jugador técnico pero que
además es uno de los más aplicados
tácticamente ayer en ese cambio de
sistema o no de sistemas sino más bien
de estrategia poniéndolo como volante
por fuera en lugar de juan guillermo
cuadrado respondió muy bien porque
estaba hacerlo y porque es un jugador
preparado para ello creo que además
colombia llega a los penales no como
fruto del sufrimiento sino más del
mérito
lo demostró eso en los cobros
emocionalmente estaban muy fuertes para
para cobrarlos y aparece la figura david
ospina que además es el jugador con más
partidos en la selección colombiana para
para vestirse de héroe y darle esta
clasificación que creo que es merecida
para el equipo de rueda por un lado de
uruguay es una nueva frustración en un
torneo que siempre ha sido predilecto su
cuarta participación consecutiva sin
pasar de los cuartos de final y las
críticas que empiezan a aparecer a
tabares esto se va acercando un final
del ciclo sin duda tavares va a tener
que empezar a pilotar una nueva tormenta
un técnico que ha estado tanto tiempo ya
sabe cómo funciona esto el punto es que
ya los resultados empiezan a pesar y un
equipo con la jerarquía de uruguay
quedar eliminado en esta ronda pesa
mucho que es lo que le falta uruguay yo
creo que está en esa transición del
juego ayer género pero termina tomando
malas decisiones y la pregunta es si no
se está trabajando lo suficiente o si
los jugadores que están en campo no le
responden a la idea del entrenador
en este punto es muy difícil pensar que
el maestro tabárez deje la selección
uruguaya antes del fin de ciclo de
eliminatoria y del probable mundial de
qatar pero sí creo que desde la
federación uruguaya de fútbol tienen que
estar pensando cuál va a ser ese
reemplazo porque es evidente que ya se
está llegando a un ciclo por un lado del
maestro pero también de muchos jugadores
ayer en las cosas que más fallo uruguay
es generarle juego a dos cracks como
luis suárez y cavani que ya no tienen 25
años es decir la selección también tiene
que empezar a jugar diferente y esto es
lo que está pesando a la hora de ver un
juego totalmente sólido uruguay no tuvo
un partido brillante en esta copa bien
en primer de economía en semifinales en
argentina que derrotó a ecuador en
goiánia la albiceleste tuvo 12 disparos
en la primera parte inclusive uno de
messi en el palo pero recién abrió el
marcador a los 40 minutos por rodrigo de
paul tras superar un bache en el
complemento los de scaloni sellaron la
victoria con el autor- martínez y lionel
messi que marcó de tiro libre y en esa
falta previa fue expulsado piero
hincapié argentina y colombia van a
jugar la segunda semifinal del martes en
brasilia antes el lunes en río brasil y
perú de final el primero
al maracaná sara si bien en argentina no
termina de construir un partido
convincente de principio a fin pudo
definir el encuentro con un resultado
abultado como analizarse esta actuación
albiceleste yo creo que no hemos visto
ningún equipo que termine de convencer
en esta copa américa en el caso
específico de argentina creo que vimos
un messi brillante otra vez un show de
lionel messi esta vez en goiánia es un
jugador que no solo entrega dos
asistencias sino que ya empieza a cobrar
un rol en el que los jugadores que están
alrededor no siempre se la pasan sino
que entienden cómo es que puede brillar
de una mejor manera el equipo no
convence porque pareciera que después de
que empieza a ganar libera las presiones
y empieza a sufrir en algunos sectores
de la cancha pero lo que sí ha tenido
leonel scaloni es muchas variantes
parece que lo di maría- ayer fue
interesante ver jugadores ya
consolidados como the pool que que es
joven pero que ya empiezan a asumir
también estos roles en la selección es
importante termina de faltar eso no
porque no puede ser sólido o dominar los
90 minutos y bueno ahí entra a jugar el
rival el rival siempre siempre juega
va a ser un partido bastante complicado
del que el que van a tener en brasilia
las elecciones de colombia de argentina
bien dejamos ordenado el capítulo de la
copa américa y nos centramos en la
eurocopa porque ayer se definió la
segunda semifinal de este torneo en el
primer turno en bakú dinamarca se llevó
el duelo de revelaciones ante república
checa por 2 a 1 tomas de lane y casper
dolberg anotaron para los nórdicos su
patrick chic descontó el delantero
alcanzó a cristiano ronaldo en la tabla
de goleadores aunque el portugués lidera
por tener además una asistencia
luego en roma' inglaterra mostró su
mejor versión y goleó 4 a 0 a ucrania
harry caine por duplicado harry maguire
y jordan henderson firmaron la
aplastante victoria así quedaron
entonces en las semifinales de la
eurocopa que se define completamente en
wembley italia-españa jugarán el martes
e inglaterra dinamarca lo harán en
miércoles tras lograr la clasificación
esto dijeron los seleccionadores
estamos en una semifinal debido al
espíritu colectivo en muchos aspectos
por supuesto la calidad de juego también
es importante pero hemos visto muchos
equipos salir de estos torneos porque el
espíritu
ha sido como el de estos muchachos eso
es algo especial que hay que reconocer
esto
simplemente es increíble ver a este
equipo cómo reaccionaron luego de lo de
herencias cuánta compasión y amor se
dieron entre ellos y también al pueblo
danés estamos felices y orgullosos de
que quizás podamos recordar porque
jugamos al fútbol y que puede hacer el
fútbol por el mundo de anwar fútbol que
new and world será en inglaterra quizá
firmó su actuación más convincente hasta
aquí en la eurocopa agregando gol a lo
que es su habitual solidez defensiva es
eso es un equipo sin fisuras este de
south gate y ha preparado cambios
estratégicos e incluso de nombres pero
el resultado sigue siendo el mismo un
equipo que no recibe goles y que ahora
también en lo en lo ofensivo empieza a
generar esas conexiones a hielo sterling
y yo fue fundamental estar en qué
jugador tan desequilibrante y como decía
creo que esa otra parte del espíritu de
está inglaterra ayer lo vimos pelota
quieta le dimos solidez aparece came no
dejaron respirar no dejaron pensar a
ucrania y sin duda desde
la manera de competir que ha sido
cuestionada por servir porque siempre se
quiere digamos un poco más de vistosidad
o de esa conexión ofensiva en tanto
talento que tiene pero creo que el plan
de saudi que está muy claro y llegan muy
fuertes a estas finales ya en wembley
por el otro lado tenemos a esta
dinamarca que es un equipo que se ha
ganado el cariño de todos no sólo por el
episodio de eriksen sino también por ese
fútbol ofensivo desprejuiciado que están
ensayando en la eurocopa uno de los
equipos quizás con italia que más ataca
en lo que va del torneo y ayer animaron
un lindo partido con otra de las
revelaciones que fue república checa las
declaraciones del entrenador son
bellísimos porque hablan de eso otro no
de las motivaciones que son necesarias
en el fútbol para conseguir resultados
pero sí cuando se habla del fútbol de
dinamarca es un fútbol que desde la
movilidad posicional en ataque es
impresionante y de las variantes que
tiene para llegar al arco rival ellos
juegan en corto pueden jugar en largo y
los centros ayer el de madre fue una
cosa espectacular son también su clave
19 centros ayer al área esa capacidad de
definición esa capacidad de ir al centro
y luego
es raro cuando uno habla de trabajo en
el fútbol porque todos los equipos
trabajan pero luego hay digamos que
sincronía y cosas que se notan en la
cancha que hablan también de un equipo
muy convencido en la idea que les da el
entrenador dinamarca sin duda no solo
animador sino uno de los que ha mostrado
también un estilo diferente pero muy
interesante en esta eurocopa y una
promesa de buen fútbol seguramente en
esas semifinales contra inglaterra en
diario de copas se repasamos otras
noticias vinculadas a estos dos torneos
españa retomó los entrenamientos en la
ciudad del fútbol de las rozas de cara a
la semifinal con italia pablo sarabia
con una dolencia muscular y américa
porque arrastra una fatiga son los
jugadores a recuperar por luis enrique
este lunes en la roja partida a londres
para afrontar el partido en wembley
sin tiempo para descanso brasil prepara
la semifinal de la copa américa ante
perú y te evalúa opciones para
reemplazar a camille jesús expulsado
ante chile abril barbosa podría ingresar
para mantener el cuarteto de atacantes
otra alternativa es el lukas para que
está autor del gol del triunfo en los
cuartos de final
y perú también encara su preparación
para el duelo de este lunes con brasil
en río de janeiro la misión de ricardo
gareca es encontrarle reemplazo andrés
carrillo una de sus figuras expulsado
ante paraguay fortalecer el medio con
wilder cartagena mantener el esquema
actual o incluir a santiago ormeño para
jugar con dos delanteros son algunas de
las posibles variantes
bueno hasta aquí llegamos con diego de
copas ensalada muchísimas gracias por tu
compañía y ya estaremos pendientes de
esto que ocurra entre brasil y perú se
vienen días de mucho análisis y de
disfrutar estos dos torneos que nos han
dejado mucho ya ustedes muchas gracias
por estar del otro lado sigan con más en
france 24 y france24 puntocom muchas
gracias